- No, I do stand up still.
I do whatever,
I try to do movies here and there.
And now with the talk show,
I do a lot.
That's tougher than I thought.
Is this tougher than you thought or no?
- Okay, you're gonna hate my answer.
I was terrified to do this
and it's way easier than I thought.
- It is?
- Yeah.
- Well tell me the secret because I think
I'm trying too hard.
- I really like people.
- No I don't,
that's what it is.
(audience laughing)
That's the big--
- You know what, I have
had this conversation
with other hosts and I'm like,
I think there's a difference,
I genuinely really like even jerks.
I like getting in there and trying to...
It's a challenge to kind of win them over.
- You know what, I think
maybe the tough part is,
'cause I cry every night and
it's not always about that.
But I sometimes,
because ours is like three comedians
and then we have topics of
the day and we talk about it
and then we do jokes and stuff.
So I sort of have to prep more.
And maybe I wanna, I just put...
I get up early.
Listen, I'm no workaholic.
You might as well know now.
So, all my friends know this.
So I just thought, I breeze in at what,
12:00 leave at 12:40.
That sounds like a good job.
And I also have made them
pay me in casino chips,
it's so stupid, right?
I have to drive up to
Morongo every weekend.
So it's a little harder than I thought,
but I do love it.
It's fun to do a job.
Like you seem like you love this.
And--
- Yeah.
- It's nice because I get...
I'm a comedian, so I'm
around funny people.
The writers are funny and
I bring great people on.
So it's overall, it's a good time.